شكرا عثمان ولعلي سانطي في غلاف غزه التي
اشرنا اليها حيث كان هناك حديث عن ذوي
سفارات الاندار وذلك في المناطق الشماليه
من قطاع غزه وتحديدا في مستوطنه ياد
مردخاي وحديث عن اطلاق صاروخ من المناطق
الشماليه باتجاه هذه المستوطنات لكن هذا
التطور ياتي في ظل التطورات اللافته خصوصا
في المنطقه الشماليه من قطاع غزه ولكن
ايضا في المناطق الجنوبيه وفي تفاصيل
المشهد ربما نشير الى هذه الاعلانات
لكتائب القسام وايضا لسريا القدس عن عمليه
استهداف هنا في المناطق الغربيه والمناطق
الجنوبيه الغربيه من مدينه غزه من خلال
الحديث عن استهداف اليات وايضا تجمعات
لجنود جيش الاحتلال في هذه المناطق وذلك
باستخدام
قذائف وايضا صواريخ 107 في التفاصيل ايضا
ربما نشير الى ما ذكرته سرايا القدس ايضا
عن استهداف اليات وايضا استهداف جنود في
مناطق الصبره ولكن ايضا في منطقه تل
الهواء وهذه المناطق التي نشير اليها وهي
مسرح لاشتباكات تاخذها المقاومه وهي
المحاور الغربيه والجن الجنوبيه الغربيه
من مدينه غزه تشير اليها ايضا هارت
الاسرائيليه من خلال حديث مسؤولين
اسرائيليين على انه يبدو بان الاشتباكات
تعود الى منطقه الشمال من قطاع غزه لو
ذهبنا الى المناطق الوسطى لعل البارس ايضا
ما اعلنته ايضا المقاومه عن استهدافات هنا
في هذه المواقع في منطقه المصدر ولكن ايضا
في شرق مخيم المغازي استهداف لاليات وايضا
لتجمعات لجنود جيش الاحتلال نذكر بان هذه
المناطق ربما تكون قريبه من السياج الفاصل
خصوصا في المناطق الوسطى وسط حديث عن نيه
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في اقامه منطقه
عازله على طول الحدود بعمق نحو كيلومتر لو
ذهبنا في النهايه الى المناطق الجنوبيه
وتحديدا طبعا خان يونس خانيونس بتطوراته
لعل ابرز ما هذه التطورات هو استمرار
عمليه القص في المناطق الشماليه المناطق
ايضا الجنوبيه وايضا المناطق الوسطى من
خان يونس نحن نتحدث بالتاكيد عن مخيم خان
يونس ومنطقه الامل وربما نختم بالاشاره
الى تطور لافت وهو ما تعلق بهذه الاحزمه
الناريه التي كنا اشرنا اليها امس بين خان
يونس ومخيم رفح وحديث رويترز نقلا عن
مسؤول اسرائيلي
بانها ستدرس مع مصر اقامه
عمليه تمشيط ان صح القول في مخيم رفح وسط
تساؤلات عن القادم في هذا المخيم وطبعا
عمليات القصف المكثفه خصوصا للمناطق
الشرقيه من رفح اذا عثمان هذه ابرز
التطورات على الجبهات الشماليه الوسطى
والجنوبيه